(gazouillis d'oiseaux)
- La forêt amazonienne,
c'est près de 400 milliards
d'arbres qui produ qui produ qut
une vapeur d'eau qui
se concentre en précipitations
qui arrosent une grande partie
de l'Amérique du sud.
Le Brésil possède plus de
60 % de cette forêt tropicale.
L'Amazonie brésilienne brûle
depuis le début de l'année,
encore plus qu'en 2020,
année re
En septembre seulement
30 000 foyers d'incendie ont été
repérés par les satellites.
lement d'oiseau)
L'an dernier pour la première
fois, l'Amazonie émettait
à certains moments plus de CO2
qu'elle en absorbait.
Au sud, les marais du Pantanalst
en savane. Les animaux,
dont le jaguar, sont en danger.
Les harpies féroces,
ces énormes rapaces,
al à se nourrir.
(cri d'harpie)
Depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
de Jair Bolsonaro le 1er janvier
2019, les incendies ont augmenté
de 75 % par rapport
à la décennie précédente.
Une catastrophe, disent
les écologistes.
"Le bilan du gouvernement
Bolsonar.
La déforestation a augmenté
de façon galopante,
bien plus que pendant
ernières années."
(vrombissement de scie à chaîne)
Le processus est bien connu
et se déroule dans la plus
parfaite illégalit,
on coupe le bois précieux.
(vrombissement de scie à chaîne)
... puis, on brûle
la forêt qui reste...
(beuglement)
... et on la transforme
en pâturages pour l'élevage
l.l.l.l.l.l.l.
Suivent les routes et
les mines d'or clandestines :
des carrières à ciel ouvert ou
le dragage 24 heures par jour
du fond de la rivière Madeira
par des barges.
Les orpailleurs isolent l'oravet
et dont les vapeurs retombent
en pur mercure dans l'eau,
qui empoisonne les populations.
"On tue la population indigène,
car l'État, par son absence,
octroie un vrai permislité en A.
Le déboisement est illégal,
les mines sont illégales.
En Amazonie, il n'y ani loi nni"
"C'est l'évidence,
la destruction de l'Amazonie
entraîne une baisse des pluies
pour le Cerrado et de la
pollution jusqu'à Sao Paulo.
L'Amazonie est notre plus grande
richesse, il faut la protéger.
Ce n'est pas une question
de droite ou de gauche."
L'ex-président Luiz Ignacio
Lula Da Silva veut faire
de la question du climat
sa grande priorité.
n gouvernement
a eu un assez bon bilan,
sa tâche ne sera pas facile
vu l'ampleur du désordre et
s écologistes
pensent que la solution passe
par les communautés indigènes,
les gardiens de la forêt, territ
être mieux protégés.
L'avenir de l'Amazonie et
son impact sur le réchauffement
climatique sont loin de
préoccuper tous les Brésiliens
si l'on en juge par l'appui
surprenant qu'ils ont donné à
Jair Bolsonaro au premier tour.
Mais l'enjeu est de taille
et, le 30 octobre prochain,
les yeux de la planète seront
tournés vers le Brésil.
Ici Jean-Michel L